hey out there welcome in welcome to a
another very interesting and I hope
timely edition of Market takes we are
with you on a Friday morning it's about
1101 eastern time here in New York City
I'm Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal and we are going live
we're talking all about today's uh pce
inflation report from the government the
Bureau of economic analysis as well as
the University of Michigan's consumer
sentiment index both of those came out
and both of those I think are very
telling about the state of the economy
and I think the market really is
starting to price some of those things
in and look long term if you are a
long-term investor some of the data we
got this morning is a little concerning
and I'm gonna break down just why that
is and talk about what's happening and
what's really moving short-term
investors it seems like the market right
now is doing all right recovering from
those big sell-offs that we had seen
last weekend at the start of this week
but we'll dive into all of that in just
a moment first I want to to start off
getting into what we saw from those two
big reports we're going to talk about
the consumer sentiment index from the
University of Michigan we're also going
to talk about the pce report and also
its potential impact on what we see next
from the Federal Reserve its next rate
decision coming in November
um also like I said we're going to talk
about the markets everything that's
moving stocks bonds Commodities
currencies talk a little crypto we're
going to do all that later on and we're
going to look ahead to what comes next
because it's not just about what
happened right and analyzing that it's
about what it means for what comes next
and what happens next in the market and
with the economy um so we're going to do
all that we're going to get into all
that but first I want to take a quick
second to just talk about the situation
right now there's this crazy situation
going on in the UK the bank of England
stepping into markets just wanted to
really quickly talk about that and how
it impacts or could impact the U.S and
our markets here now if you've seen
headlines about a guilt sell-off you
know like what what is that basically UK
government bonds in government bonds are
called guilts and so you've seen just a
huge rapid sell-off unprecedented
selling of bonds yields spiking up as
you know when prices go down yields go
up on bonds so the government bonds
having a huge sell-off that was reversed
after the bank of England stepped in but
that was pretty I don't want to call it
unprecedented action but it was action
that meant a whole lot because the bank
of England has been trying to raise
rates tighten monetary conditions
tighten policy and that sort of goes
against their mission really what
happened was you saw this huge sell-off
in UK government debt that created a big
problem and some dysfunction in the
pension system and the bank of England
saw that and said okay we have to act we
have to step in and stop the sell-off
that's notable for a number of reasons
not just because of the bond market but
because if the bank of England is trying
to raise rates to fight inflation well
when they're stepping into the market to
buy Bonds doing essentially quantitative
easing they're sort of working against
themselves and that could be something
if you see more of this action from
other central banks where they're you
know they're trying to fight inflation
by raising rates and tightening policy
and choking off the economy but they
have to do quantitative easing and step
in and buy bonds which lowers Bond rates
which makes the economy easier which
makes monetary conditions flow more
smoothly we could see some
unusual things happening so keep your
eyes peeled for that I just wanted to
take a second to talk about that fed
Vice chair Leo Brainerd out this morning
saying a morning quote we should
consider spillovers as ratings tight as
rates tighten globally essentially what
that means is some of this drama we're
seeing unfold in the UK in the Eurozone
in China that could spill over as rates
get tighter as monetary policy gets more
restrictive and it gets more expensive
to buy things and to borrow money so all
that said Leo brainerdout this morning
with a bit of a warning I think that's I
think that's useful to keep in mind as
we look through this data and as we talk
about the potential for a U.S recession
and a global recession moving forward so
anyway all that to say this is the
reason we watch the data because right
now we're at a situation where markets
are very bearish there's a lot of fear
out there and the question is are we
heading into a recession are things
about to get worse and and start really
falling off a cliff or is this the
bottom and now is a great buying
opportunity because the Market's going
to pick back up and things are going to
start to get better and now is the time
to really invest and get into the market
because things are about to improve this
is why we watch the data so let's let's
dive into that so we got two reports
today University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index showed that sentiment
was actually down it fell over the
course of the month sentiment up from
where it was in August but down through
the course of September I'll explain
what that means in just a second that's
kind of the biggest takeaway is that
cinnamon is better in September than it
was in August but it got worse through
the course of September we'll dig into
all that the pce report that's part of
the consumer
uh income and outlays Report or the
personal income and outlays report that
the government puts out that showed
higher inflation across the board uh
higher than expected and and inflation
really not moving in the direction of
the Federal Reserve and most consumers
like you and me would like to see that
move
so really inflation no matter how you
measure it is not getting better is not
going down at the speed that I think
policy makers would like we're going to
dive into all that but first let's talk
about this consumer sentiment index
number from the University of Michigan I
it was lower than the initial reporter
lower than expectations and lower than
the initial report came in at 58.6 that
was below the 59.5 number from the
initial report it's small potatoes but
it does mean that you know through the
second half or the back half of the
month as more data came in people felt
worse about the economy and we had hit
those those long time lows on consumer
sentiment back in June when gas prices
were just spiking and spiraling out of
control and we had come back from that
we'd been moving in this positive
direction in terms of consumer sentiment
people were feeling better and now we
might be seeing that Trend stop and
reverse to where we could be getting
worse again
um the the media expectation for
inflation those have come down down at
4.7 percent for one year ahead that's
the lowest in September 2021 that's the
good news also five-year tenure
inflation dropped down to 2.7 percent
from 2.8 percent all that means is we're
moving closer to the fed's Target
inflation expectations anchored around
two percent is the idea so that's the
good news folks aren't getting more
worried about inflation and that has a
lot to do with gas prices coming down
uh now the bad news here's what the
University of Michigan had to say in
their report quote inflation
expectations are likely to remain
relatively unstable in the months ahead
as consumer uncertainty over these
expectations remained high and is
unlikely to wane in the face of
continued Global pressures on inflation
um the big picture here is while gas
prices have come down and that's what a
lot of people have been talking about
food prices and housing prices have
continued to tick up and that's why
we're seeing you know these inflation
readings come in higher than expected
again we're going to dig more into that
in just a minute but when we talk about
consumer sentiment that's very tied to
inflation and very tied to what folks
are having to pay at the grocery store
their monthly rent and all those things
we're seeing that continue to go higher
some interesting numbers to pull out
here from the report uh the the reading
was down 19.5 percent from September
2021 so we're down almost 20 percent
from where consumer sentiment was about
a year ago you saw modest declines in
the long run outlook for business for
business conditions again folks starting
to feel less excited less you know good
about the face of business and you saw a
Divergence in the consumer conditions so
the current conditions report folks
talking about how they feel right now
that Rose to 59.7 so that went up but
when folks started looking out to the
Future expectations that was almost two
points lower at 58. so that's not a good
thing and the University of Michigan
said I want to read another quote to you
Trends are consistent with a recession
to come Trends are consistent with a
recession to come
particularly as conditions overseas
generate further downside risk to the
economy so again you've got the
University of Michigan also talking
about overseas potential spillovers
right in different words where this
tumult that we're seeing in the UK the
uh the EU China this Russia Ukraine
conflict all of these things could
potentially spill over have an effect on
the U.S keep that in mind and and watch
out for that because that could be
something the Federal Reserve starts
talking more about and maybe they've got
to start raising rates even more
um look let's talk about pce that
inflation report because inflation right
now is everything the big takeaway
higher than expected inflation across
the board core prices headline prices
all the pieces of the report show
inflation higher than expected coming in
more than economists had predicted and
that's not a good thing what that means
to the Federal Reserve is they can't
turn around and say oh we'll see apis I
have a PC is coming down both are moving
in the opposite direction moving higher
than the Federal Reserve wants them to
move and so that means the fed's got to
keep tightening it's very likely and
it's likely that they're going to have
to do more on inflation or at least that
they'll they will feel compelled based
on what we've heard from Fed chair Jay
Powell what we've heard from others on
the Federal Reserve and the Federal Open
markets committee the folks who make
those decisions the fed's gonna have to
keep raising rates
uh you saw a 6.2 percent uh compared to
expectations of 6.0 percent on the
headline number up a little bit on the
month but core rates up 0.6 percent
that's when you strip out food and
energy right which are very volatile so
when we just look at things like housing
things like what you're paying at the
grocery store uh things with what you're
paying at the at the convenience store
all those things are moving up
consistently and you saw 0.6 increase
and a five and a 4.9 year-over-year
increase
um that's getting back close to those
Peak numbers to the core that we saw
back in February and the headline rate
the highest that we saw in the headline
was seven percent we're getting back
close to that at 6.2 percent so
inflation not coming down maybe we
haven't peaked that's again something
for the market to keep its eye on I also
want to talk about the because this is
all part of the personal income and
outlays report that the Bureau of
economic analysts puts out Bureau of
economic analysis excuse me
um they also talked about personal
income Rising but spending Rose 0.4
percent of the month that was twice the
estimate what we're seeing is consistent
and continued spending folks paying
higher prices and what we're seeing is
the savings rate declined to 3.5 percent
that's up from a 14-year low in June but
just barely so savings rate is declining
the normal savings rate is about six or
seven percent that's the long-term
historical average so we're doing about
half that right now Americans are not
saving and they are increasing what
they're spending significantly how are
they doing that they're taking on a lot
more credit Bank of America out this
morning with a report on U.S credit card
debt I want to read you a little bit
from that we estimate that the average
household currently carries 8 537 in
credit card debt as of July exceeding
Peak levels last seen in May 2008 of 8
396. so about two hundred dollars more
average credit card debt for the average
U.S household than we saw in May 2008
which was the previous record high
record high credit card debt right now
for American consumers low savings rate
getting down to a savings rate that we
haven't seen in about 15 years since
when 2007 uh these are things that
you've got to keep your eye on in terms
of the the economy and what we could see
now why does the fedwatch PC versus CPI
CPE uh just reflects more consumer
substitution if you were buying steak
and now you're buying ground beef that
goes into pce also PC is more about
businesses than consumers CPI looks at
what consumers are doing what they're
spending whereas PC looks at what
businesses are taking in that's what the
FED is more concerned about and so if
you're watching and trying to predict
what's the FED gonna do are they going
to be more aggressive are they going to
do more on the economy you want to look
at the pce and that's what we got today
again higher than expected higher than
expected for the year higher than
expected for the month higher than
expected on the core when you strip out
food and energy all of that so that
suggests that there is a lot more that
the FED can do and a lot more of the FED
is likely to do let's take a step back
check out wsg a.com and look at the
market right now you've got stocks
really rising up into the green all
higher the Dow the s p the NASDAQ the
NASDAQ actually up over one percent
again if you're a short-term investor
and you're a Trader this is looking good
maybe now is the time to buy maybe you
should have bought this morning at the
open when things were a little lower and
now they're looking better but to me
this looks like a bounce back from
earlier rather than a fundamentally
driven move when we look at the bond
market we are seeing a little bit of
worry there in the long-term bonds
you're seeing the 30 year and the
10-year both down a little bit on yields
so a little bit of buying and the long
dated the longer dated bonds really
across the board you're seeing yields
down just a bit kind of recovering from
an early bond yield fall where yields
went down because a lot of folks were
buying those bonds uh worried about the
data you're seeing that kind of reverse
as folks come into the market maybe
buying that dip currencies you've got
the Euro and dollar are about even
Japanese Yen uh the dollar up just a
little bit the UK pound that's the big
one to watch right now the pound is up
about point four five percent so up over
110 that means folks are getting a
little bit more bullish on the Euro on
the UK economy which is definitely a
good thing uh Bitcoin spiking ethereum
up uh really crypto across the board is
up big uh about three percent up on
bitcoin so the market really having a a
good day and is bullish right now about
things are about where things are it
seems like these negative reports uh the
long termers are getting you know kind
of outshined by the short termers here
but definitely if you're a long-term
investor if you're just someone who's
concerned about the you know the outlook
for the economy today's data was not
good so what comes next well we will be
right here on Market takes talking
through the non-farms payrolls report
the non-farm payroll support aka the job
support next Friday I hope you will be
right here with me I know you can be
anywhere in the world but you know I
appreciate you being here with me today
and I hope you'll be with me next week
as we break down the jobs report that's
the next big piece of data if the jobs
report shows you know continued hiring
that's going to put more pressure on
inflation and that's going to put more
pressure on the FED to maybe think hey
we've got to do more because we're not
seeing the Slowdown the FED has really
and Fed chair Jay Powell have really
pointed to that jobs market and said
we've got to slow this thing down I
don't know and there's a lot of
economists out there who are who are
saying I don't know that that's the key
I don't know that that's the way to go
that jobs are really the problem because
we've seen that job and wage inflation
has not kept up with the overall pace of
inflation but the FED has said we want
to see that come down so we will need to
see if the jobs report shows that
inflation's coming down and maybe the
FED can be a little less aggressive
uh so the 7th of October be there or be
a
we'll be right here on Market takes we
are also going to do a look ahead the
following week on that Monday to the CPI
and the PPI reports those will be coming
out in mid-october so keep your eyes on
those listen I'm Dion we're Bowen this
is Market takes for the Wall Street
Journal thank you so much for tuning in
and we will be right back here with you
next week next Friday for more